Christa Stephano has just changed his
podcast forever with the addition of a
brand new co-host one of his oldest
friends in comedy Mr Mike Cannon folks
look at him look at Mike Cannon he's
going to be on every episode we've
pre-recorded some episodes that he
wasn't a part of so we're going to edit
this exact thing I'm saying into every
episode Mike Cannon has been a guest on
almost a dozen episodes of chrisy chaos
which makes it even cooler to see him
become the new full-time co-host of the
show plus Chris and Mike have both done
interviews for this channel the podcast
now Chris and Chaos with Mike Cannon
until it starts to make enough money
where it'll just be the Chris and Mike
show or until I eventually one day quit
where it'll just be Mike's Mike Cannon's
long running podcast here's the scenario
with Mike feny and brandan saglo just
officially ended so it's great that